[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
the good people over at learn Liberty
today and joining me is an assistant
professor of economics at the University
of Tampa and an affiliated scholar with
both the Mercatus Center and the
foundation for economic education dr.
abby hall welcome to the rubin report
thank you for having me
how was my intro there I feel good about
that good work I liked it all right
there's a lot I want to get into it you
because I was looking at your bio and a
lot of the stuff that you talked about
that you specialize in is stuff but I
really like that we haven't done a ton
on so can we jump into foreign policy
first sure foreign policy to me seems
like one of the craziest things that we
have going on these days because
everyone's talking about it and yet it
seems like no one knows what they're
talking about is that a generally fair
statement I'll start us off on here that
just everyone's always talking about all
this stuff and nobody really knows
what's going on
not nobody but the masses if it's
comforting at all having a lot of
foreign policy issues that people know
nothing about it is not anything that is
new to today however I would say that
foreign policy is an area where a lot of
people are I think rationally fairly
ignorant just because a lot of foreign
policy people think I think often
incorrectly that foreign policy doesn't
have any kind of impact on what's going
on domestically yeah so I like that you
set it up that way that it's not
necessarily any worse now I think it
seems like it's somehow worse now
because of social media so you just see
people all day long who you know don't
really know what they're saying and
they're constantly saying things but as
someone that knows a bit about foreign
policy what are what are some of the
tenants you need in a solid sound
foreign policy a complicated question
why are you it is what I'm I don't I
don't pretend to be able to sit from my
position and prescribe foreign policy
that is not what I see my role as an
economist
as being but I can say that economics
gives us a lot of insights as to how we
should expect foreign policy to work or
in a lot of cases to not work in the way
that it's intended whether we're talking
about humanitarian interventions or if
we're talking about military
intervention economics and the
frameworks that are given to us so that
we can talk about from an economic
perspective are helpful in understanding
what's going on with a lot of foreign
policy yeah how much of our foreign
policy is directly economically based
like we like to think oh we do this for
humanitarian reasons or we do this
because of some other reason but is it
at the end of the day is it like 90
percent that's really just about
economics it's hard to describe
something as being just economic as I
try to pitch my students when they're in
class everything is an economic problem
if you look at it hard enough as the
economics propel course but if you look
at a foreign intervention there is
absolutely what we would call the public
choice aspect of foreign policy what
Dwight Eisenhower referred to as a
military-industrial complex so you have
congressional leaders you have the
Pentagon you have private interest who
all have a vested interest in engaging
and foreign policy or particular types
of foreign policy I should say
regardless of whether or not it's
actually productive we're serving the
quote unquote common good yeah when you
say particular types you talk about some
sort of military intervention base
military intervention although one thing
that we have observed for the last
several decades humanitarian
interventions are becoming more and more
something that's falling under the
umbrella of military execution
regardless of whether or not that's
appropriate yeah so when you see
something like Syria going on right now
there's a humanitarian disaster are they
bringing in economists to say guys we
there's a humanitarian disaster there's
there's people you know hundreds of
thousands of something like five hundred
thousand people have died over the last
eight years or something like that like
what are the
economic choices we have to make to make
this viable or is it just that the
machine just kind of exists and they're
just going to make the decisions and do
what they want I can't say that I know
exactly what the Obama administration
went now the Trump administration are
doing as far as consulting economists
about what to do in Syria unfortunately
and this has been a point of a lot of
the research that I've done is people
tend to think about foreign intervention
as being something really simple it's a
math problem or very just linear here's
a problem we want to get from this point
to that point and here's a solution
that's supposed to fix it so we go from
A to B to C but unfortunately that is
not how things work as I ever worked
that way no it has ever been made
amusing no not that I'm aware of um
things are not linear like that and so
when you think about issues especially
something this is a complex foreign
policy where you are dealing with
millions of actors and parts of you know
M economy social issues political issues
all of those things are coming together
and they're working or not working but
when you intervene in one place in that
system it's totally just fantastic
thinking to look at that and go sure if
we intervene at one part in the system
there's no way that there's going to be
an impact in other parts of that system
as well and that's where you wind up
running into some really on nefarious
unintended consequences which we have
seen over and over and over right it is
also sort of the idea of like mission
creep where they you know they always
sort of have one goal and then it keeps
becoming another goal and another goal
and another goal and then you don't even
know where you started at the beginning
maybe part of that so when we talk about
mission creep that's certainly part of
the economics of bureaucracy and one
thing about foreign intervention of
really any flavor whether we're talking
about humanitarian aid or we're talking
about war it's all done in this
bureaucratic regime so overlapping
layers of bureaucracy bureaucratic firms
don't compete for profit like a standard
firm one so anyway I typically explain
it
you have a for-profit firm they look at
their financial statements at the end of
the quarter they're earning a profit
that's indicating to them that they are
providing something that is adding value
to society a negative profit or a loss
indicates the opposite bureaucracies
however they're not competing for profit
or loss they are competing for
government resources the pieces of some
larger budget how do they convey that
they should get a bigger piece of that
budget that they should have more
personnel by taking on more and more
activities which are important to the
powers that be yes so just to be clear
they basically they're competing for
this budget so they have to spend money
even in cases where they wouldn't have a
good reason to is that fair to say
absolutely there's no incentive to cost
minimize right if you are deceptive
right I mean there's reasons not to do
it I should value a budget will be cut
right you if I'm if I'm a government
agency and I go to you as the federal
government and I say hey I can do the
exact same job that I'm doing with 20
percent less money the next year I'm
going to have 20 percent less like logit
which is not what you're incentivized to
do as somebody operating a bureaucracy
now this doesn't mean that the people
who are working in the government are
necessarily you know terrible people who
are sitting there wringing their hands
trying to get as much money as possible
but as an economist we look at that and
we say well this is the incentive
structure that they face so how did that
system get built I mean how did this
come to be it's now I'm not an economist
but it sounds quite ridiculous I would
want something that was slim and trim
and took as little from the people as
possible and that could you know every
year become more efficient and need less
resources and all that and that's quite
literally the reverse of what we had one
thing about this bureaucratic system is
that there is that incentive to expand
not saying that it's not possible to
constrain it but there's actually an
entire branch of economics called
constitutional political economy which
is trying to answer the question of if
we want something like a government who
will provide quote unquote national
defense or roads or education whatever
you want to put in that bucket how do we
construct a political system where we
can impact
our our leaders to do the things that we
want them to do and yet simultaneously
constrain them right to not go outside
of those stated confines that we would
prefer where those functions that we
want them to fulfill in terms of how we
got there I it's a tricky question
requires a lot of historical knowledge
my experience is looking at how things
have evolved militarily particularly
that military industrial complex because
we've always seen a relationship between
private actors and public actors that's
nothing that's new however this massive
kind of military spending that we have
right now is not something that has
always been observed in the u.s. yeah
and that really starts I think if you
want to pinpoint it during the interwar
years between World War one and World
War two because you've got contracting
rules that change so it used to be if I
had an idea for something that the
military could use I would pitch that
idea to various boards they would look
at it they would look to see it was a
good idea they've done out bids but now
and this kind of started during that
period the rules of the game have
changed for those kinds of contracts so
instead of who can build something the
cheapest it might be oh these we have a
relationship with this particular
company or they're familiar with our
processes and so it's built up over time
do you think there's any kind of
functional way to roll back some of that
I mean if you wanted to get the system
if you wanted to have a fair bidding
process or something that was going to
be a little more fiscally responsible
any of that is it possible to roll back
things that are inside of such a massive
complex as you're mentioning I would
like to say that I think anything is
possible I'm not sure that I think it's
particularly likely yeah you have
massive entrenched interest for I mean
you look at something like drones or
tanks there have been a tank for example
that the military has said for years we
do not want them yeah and yet they
continue to be manufactured
and they are quite literally sitting in
a compound somewhere and they are just
rusting yeah why are we still
manufacturing these it's because the
places where they're manufactured their
elected officials keenly aware of the
fact that if they shut down these
factories some of their constituency is
going to be unemployed that does not
bode well for their reelection they
fight really hard to keep those things
in place and so you're fighting those
battles yeah at so many different
junctures I'm honestly not really sure
what it would what it would take
yeah how could you even start to fight
that at the political level because
you'd have to have a politician who'd be
willing to say to his own people you're
going to lose some jobs because it's the
unfortunately in this case it's the
right thing to do right and that we
don't get maybe politicians like that no
and there's actually a famous economist
named FA Hyack who in chapter 10 of his
book the Road to Serfdom talks about why
the worst get on top so why it is that
you are unlikely to have those kinds of
political officials get into place
because the people who are going to seek
out those positions and people who are
going to importantly be successful in
those positions are not other people who
are going to say let's take one for the
team and roll roll back these policies
people like to think and economists make
this mistake as well that political
officials are publicly interested so
they set aside their own incentives
their own desires and instead they're
trying to fulfill some broader notion of
the public good so they've set it up
oftentimes what's called a social
welfare function so you put societal
welfare on one side of the equal sign
and if you just have all of your math
correct on the other sides and we can
make people as happy as possible but
this really ignores things that you
learn on quite literally day one of your
economics classes right that people
respond to incentives so political
actors just like any other actor facing
scarcity we should expect that they're
going to respond to incentives
yeah is there any sensible way to
disconnect the politics from the way
that the military is run and funded
uh-huh yeah I mean it's sort of the same
question that I asked you before but is
there some possible way that we could
have some sort of some sort of
go-between between those two things so
that they could run more efficiently
it's tricky because oftentimes when
people look and even people who
acknowledge that maybe there is an issue
with military spending or the u.s. is
too involved militarily which can get
you in hot water very very quickly
because military is one of the sacred
cows in the United States people will
suggest doing different kinds of things
well maybe you should limit lobbying or
campaign contributions or something like
that but again we go back to one of the
first things that we learn in economics
which is that when you have scarcity so
when people are competing for resources
that competition is ever-present whether
you are competing in the marketplace for
profit if you are in a bureaucracy and
you are competing for pieces of
government budget just because you
change the system not going to change
the fact that there's competition there
but so that entire field looking at how
do we devise right this is kind of a
funny place for an economist to be
because you're dealing in a system that
doesn't deal with the normal rules of an
economy so I mean it's it isn't it isn't
like I can see because oftentimes when
people look at economists they think
that we are exclusively looking at how
markets operate but economics is much
more fundamentally about human
interaction so given the fact that
resources are scarce and people respond
to incentives how is it that people
coordinate in exchange with each other
and in that case then economics is much
more broad in terms of the scale and the
scope of what it is that economics can
talk about
[Music]
you